Avengers endgame delivers an epic
conclusion for the MCU founding fathers
Tony Stark and Steve Rogers and that
spectacular ending is one that Marvel
carefully constructed laying an
intricate trail of clues over the past
22 movies
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm Jon and
today I'm excited to reveal all the
foreshadowing and hidden symbolism in
the MCU that cleverly predicted Iron
Man's ultimate destiny plus I'll be
breaking down every amazing detail you
might have missed in the end game finale
and explaining what it means for the
future of the MCU to celebrate the
film's release I'm kicking off a special
Marvel giveaway subscriber leave a
comment about the movie for a chance to
win obviously we're in the end game now
for spoilers so take care if you haven't
seen the movie yet the Stan himself says
in this movie or the journey is the end
and in the final big battle after it
seemed like the mad Titan would win yet
again Tony made the ultimate sacrifice
stealing back the Infinity stones from
Thanos and snapping them in his own
gauntlet this dusted Thanos and his army
but also mortally wounded Tony as the
radiation from the snap burned up his
armor and body
Tony's final words to the world before
he snapped were I am Iron Man
a perfect retort to Thanos line I am
inevitable which the mad Titan uttered
just before trying and failing to snap
for the last time but more than that
Tony's final words are also a perfect
callback to the end of the first Iron
Man movie which launched the MCU I'm
just not the hero type clearly with this
laundry list of character defects all
that mistakes I made truth is I am Iron
Man
after what happened in endgame it's
interesting to look back to the Avengers
early days together for example when
Steve told Tony the only thing you
really fight for is yourself you're not
the guy to make the sacrifice play to
lay down on a wire or let the other guy
crawl over you I think I would just cut
the one yet Tony proved he was willing
to sacrifice himself with a greater good
during the Battle of New York and most
recently in endgame and even back when
he faced off with Obadiah Stane but his
ultimate sacrifice was most poignant Lee
foreshadowed in age of Ultron when Tony
talk to Nick Fury about the terrible
vision he'd seen of his legacy
Scarlet Witch induce a vision and Tony
but it was a
product of his own fears about the
future and as he explained to Fiore what
he dreaded most wasn't dying but that
he'd watched the others die while he
survived and I'm the man have killed the
Avengers so I'm on that Nick thought
that the whole world too
I was shown was the nightmare was my
legacy the end of the path I started us
on some parts of Tony's missions such as
the invading leviathans and caps broken
shield did come true during the final
battle and endgame however unlike
infinity war where Tony had to watch
many of his fellow heroes turn to dust
this time he saved the Avengers and died
instead creating the legacy he wanted
indeed it's been clear since the very
first Iron Man movie just how crucial
the notion of legacy was to Tony as even
in those days the idea of leaving behind
a legacy of death was something that
weighed heavy on his mind we're a
weapons manufacturer probably just I
don't want a body count to be back then
Tony tried rewriting his legacy by
ending his company's manufacture of
weapons but that turned out to be small
potatoes compared to what he had to do
to change his legacy today we can bust
arms dealers on a live long David that
up there that's that's a game dr.
strange knew the iron man was the key to
defeating Thanos in infinity war strange
checked over 14 million scenarios and
found only one where the avengers
triumphed over the mad Titan for in time
to view alternate futures to see all the
possible outcomes of becoming conflict
how many did you see fourteen million
six hundred and five how many we win
what once dr. strange knew this he did a
complete 180 on his previous threat that
he sacrifice own man's life to save the
time stone and instead he willingly gave
the stone to Thanos in order to stop him
from killing Tony stop
spare his life and I will give you the
stone the sorcerer supreme new Ironman
had to survive through infinity war and
actually told Tony there was no other
way just before he faded to dust then an
endgame when Thanos was on the verge of
victory yet again after defeating each
of the heroes one by one dr. strange
reminded Tony that he was the only
person who could win the battle for them
he did this by turning to Tony and
holding up a single finger a reminder
that Tony's sacrifice was the one and
only way to beat Thanos looking back to
Civil War then when Hawkeye called Tony
the Futurist who sees all and knows
what's best for you whether you like it
or not although that was an Easter Egg
to both the comics and Robert Downey jr.
moosic album and although Hawkeye was
annoyed and mocking Tony when he said it
it turns out that Hawkeye's words were
pretty accurate
thanks to dr. strange Tony was the only
living avenger who realized there was
just a single way to win the war that
they were waging once and for all as
Thanos said an infinity war Tony was
indeed cursed with knowledge Tony's
death is of course heartbreaking as his
friends and fellow Avengers Rhodey and
Peter Parker find him dying and pepper
comes over and tells him he can rest now
even an end game when Tony tried to stay
away from the Avengers and live a
peaceful life with his daughter Morgan
and pepper he couldn't do it when he
solved the time-travel conundrum that
the Avengers were facing he felt that he
should lock the discovery away and
destroy it so he couldn't go off on
another adventure but the pull of the
Iron Man suit and his desire to be the
hero and tech genius has always been too
strong from revealing himself as Iron
Man at the press conference in his first
film - taking on his last incredibly
dangerous mission in endgame for Tony
living and dying as Iron Man was
basically his destiny and what an
amazing 11-year journey it's been for
his character and what a long way he's
come from being a man reluctant to act
against terrorists using his company's
weapons are you going to do something
Jatayu anything they can I could kill
you either way and if they done I'm
probably dead no week to becoming a man
prepared to offer himself up for the
good of others
Tony's final stand against Thanos was
the last act of defiance of the great
Tony Stark to quote yinsen who urged
Tony not to waste his life just before
he died saving the billionaire genius in
Afghanistan and Tony certainly took
those words on board ultimately then
what Tony told Pepper back in 2008 about
his evolution turned out to be true if I
were iron man I'd have this girlfriend
who knew my true identity she'd be a
wreck she always be worrying that I was
gonna die and so proud the man I've
become should be wildly conflicted
fortunately as we see during Tony's
voiceover an endgame after his death his
legacy has been to restore the heroes
and people he was snapped away so he's
brought a happy ending to many in the
universe and for us in the audience we
can also feel Tony's legacy during the
memorial that Pepper holds for him after
she releases a wreath of flowers with
the proof that Tony Stark has a heart
arc reactor
the camera slowly pans over so many of
the wonderful characters have been
introduced to in the MCU from the very
first film through to the penultimate
movie and finally on to Nick Fury the
man who laid the groundwork to bring
them all together in the MCU very first
post-credit scene in the Iron Man movie
what this scene really represents then
is the legacy of marvelous superheroes
that Ironman has given to us the fans by
the way there's a lovely little cameo in
this funeral scene by Harley keener the
young boy who Tony met in Iron Man 3
it's actually the same actor ty simpkins
and he's standing behind Wanda Bucky and
Sam although these scenes have brought
many to tears they're still another part
to Tony's legacy which is that his
daughter Morgan looks like she's
inherited his desire to put on the Iron
Man suit she not only picks up an Iron
Man helmet from Tony's garage at the
beginning of the movie but just like her
father when happy asks Morgan what she'd
like to eat she asked for a cheeseburger
which is exactly what Tony demanded
after he was brought back from
Afghanistan there are two things I want
to do on an American cheeseburger
and the other okay drive
cheeseburger first in Tony's bath
message he also says that Morgan will
face the same forces of darkness and
light that he battled during his life
and in a tender moment he echoes his
daughter's words to him from earlier in
the movie I love you 3000 but there's
one last tribute to the great Tony Stark
which you might just have missed unless
you stayed right until the very end of
the credits rather than an actual post
credits scene we just hear the sound of
metal clanking over the Marvel Studios
logo it's a callback to the first Iron
Man movie when Tony had to forge his own
Iron Man suit while he was being held
prisoner and of course that cave scene
was also referenced at the beginning of
endgame when Tony and nebula worked
together to fix the ship's broken fuel
cells in a similar way to how Tony and
yinsen collaborated to make the suit an
Iron Man for me endgames little
post-credits teaser symbolizes not only
the Iron Man was the cornerstone of the
MCU his birth and death book ending this
chapter in the franchise's history but
also how Tony's spirit and determination
lives on in the Marvel verse and how the
work he started still continues with
Marvel busily putting together a new era
of movies TV shows and stories for fans
to enjoy Steve Rogers also got a big
send-off an endgame and I've broken down
everything you need to know about the
evolution of Captain America and the MCU
Plus what Steve's ending with Peggy
Carter really means in my next video you
can tap up right for the link to that
video or check the video description for
the link as soon as it's ready now what
do you think about Tony's ending an
endgame comment below and subscribe to
enter my marvel giveaway tapleft for
that Captain America video or tap write
for my full Marvel playlists and if you
enjoy deep dives like this about your
favorite movies hit the bell to get all
my new videos thanks for watching and
see you next time you big a movie lovers